he's a bit scatterbrained and kind of a
scaredy-pants not what you'd call the
most reliable toad in the brigade but
now our reluctant hero captain toad is
about to embark on the adventure of a
lifetime in captain toad treasure
tracker
one fine day the captain and toadette
were out searching for treasure when
suddenly a giant bird attacked
wingo lover of all things shiny grabbed
the precious power star in toadette too
now it's up to captain toad to adventure
off into the unknown to get them both
back
captain toad must explore each maze-like
mini universe
if you rotate the stage to view it from
different angles
you can find the hidden treasures and
secret passageways and make your way to
the power star at the end
captain toad's backpack weighs a ton so
he can't jump and that can be a big
problem for a little fellow who's being
chased by shy guys who never ever give
up
piranha sprouts who pop out of the
ground when you least expect them
flappers who pound down on anyone who's
foolish enough to stand under them
and a bunch of other baddies who are
trying to keep captain toad from his
treasure
but don't worry captain toad knows how
to take care of himself he can throw
turnips at his enemies to knock them out
he can swing the super pickaxe to break
down blocks and open paths he can even
create captain toad clones to help him
along the way
captain toad has his own unique moves to
help him survive even the most
challenging of situations
each stage offers something new like a
steam locomotive
slippery slides
a spooky haunted house
a dazzling pinball machine and boss
stages that have you running for cover
there are more than 70 stages for you
and the captain to explore
use the wii u gamepad to interact with
the courses and switch up the terrain in
order to puzzle your way to the goal
and when your feet get tired the captain
can always ride a mine cart through one
of the roller coaster-like stages
throwing turnips at enemies along the
way
one
join our reluctant hero on his first and
greatest treasure hunting adventure
captain toad treasure tracker